[Musique]
julie andrieu bonjour bonjour véronique
merci de participer à ce vie peu spécial
la poule du mans vous êtes ici en tant
que experts culinaires tant qu ami des
animaux
les deux à la fois et en tant qu'ami de
versailles aussi allusion à yoplait
oui j'aime beaucoup cette ville et oui
non évidemment j'ai passé un petit
moment dans la sarthe autour du mans
pour une émission il ya deux ans de cela
à peu près j'avais gardé un très bon
souvenir de ses rencontres de ce banquet
qu'on avait organisé à l'abbaye de
l'epau et de la poularde qu'on avait
cuisiné par donc pas une poule du mans
parce que je crois qu'elles sont très
rares oui mais déjà j'en ai entendu
parler et je sais que c'est une
tradition et une tradition volaillère là
bas qui est très forte pour les louer
mais je suis ravi que cette poule du
mans soit à nouveau à nouveau relancée
dollar en voilà voilà
et sinon donc vous faire ça et vous
connaissez bien vous avez une émission
et a pas très longtemps
oui on en a fait une château notamment
voilà absolument les pompiers autour du
grand canal puis récemment j'ai fait le
marché aussi pour une émission de noël
ah non je suis une fidèle êtes à fond
bon mais écoutez merci vous avez des
projets d'émissions vous êtes sur deux
émissions différentes je crois toujours
absolument à 15 heures et à 16 heures le
samedi
sur france 3 les carnets de julie dans
la version itinérante dans la version
dans ma cuisine avec des tas de
rencontres dans la france entière
néanmoins et puis des émissions avec des
chefs qui viendront de toutes les
régions qui sont à venir pour le
printemps vous savez qu'on à alain
ducasse à versailles va évidemment vous
avez fait une émission mais put alors
d'abord c'est mon éditeur donc le
connais un peu et sa femme est une amie
très proche vous dire que voilà que ce
soit pas des amis mais surtout c'est
quelqu'un que j'admire beaucoup
et alors on est allé dans son restaurant
versailles et oui aurait j'ai beaucoup
apprécié le décor et surtout la
recherche qui a été faite sur l'origine
des arts de la table pour nous resituer
dans ce monde existe au rhic sans parler
évidemment de la qualité de la cuisine
et voilà et puis j'ai eu la chance grâce
à alain baraton de pouvoir visiter le
potager du roi et maintenant le fameux
vous lie et des boules du voilà bombe a
coûté sur ce mot de la fin nous allons
terminer merci julie merci
la turbine merci à la baraton bonjour
bonjour merci d'être là où vous êtes le
jardinier en chef du trianon et grand
parc de versailles est aujourd'hui est
un grand jour car vous avez ont
accueilli en vos murs nouvelle habitante
et oui la poule du mans une poule qui
retrouve sa place qu'elle occupait du
temps de louis 15 louis 15
collectionnait les gallinacés il était
bien que cette poule qui avait menacé de
disparaître retrouve son poulailler
l'époque à savoir celui de louis 15 donc
nous sommes à trianon pour accueillir
cette poule elles sont 3 l/100 3 alors
ne craignez vous pas les prédateurs
comme versailles est un petit peu encore
sauvage wcs y avoir des renards des
fouines des restaurateurs nous sommes
jardiniers les jeunes qui connaissent la
nature ils connaissent les dangers avec
les fouines avec les oiseaux de nuit
également et donc la poule a été
installé dans un lieu justement pour
ultra protégée il n'y a aucun danger
bien évidemment elle gambadera toute la
journée le soir elle rentrera dans sa
maison et là où nous sommes il n'y a
aucun risque qu'un animal ne viennent
s'en emparer il vous êtes prêt à être
réveiller tous les matins au chant du
coq mais j'attends avec impatience un
instant merveilleux
l'idée que le coq vous rappelle que le
jour est arrivé c'est fait c'est un
bruit qui est fabuleux
je ne conçois pas qu'aujourd'hui
certains puissent protester contre le
cri de cet animal quel symbole même de
la france voilà dans leurs cousins c'est
un plaisir immense toute façon vous êtes
un homme dès l'aube non non on est un
homme d'état digne ont la réputation
d'aimer se lever tôt on fait simple je
me lève tôt mais je déteste me lever
tous d'accord on vous fait un gros
effort quand même les à france inter où
les hommes de tous les dimanches dont je
vous fais une confidence roddick c'est
que ma maman a toujours su me lever tard
et elle a longtemps hésité à croire que
j'étais vraiment en direct sur les ondes
de france inter
et elle n'en revient toujours pas que
soient ponctuels depuis 14 ans
maintenant sur france inter à cette
heure et demie tous les samedis et tous
les dimanches dans l'estimé 3 à terre
tout à fait on dirait que militante
voilà d'accord bon vous avez cette
activité là vous avez aussi une activité
vite et télévisuelle widgets sur france
5 raconté ou un petit peu car je suis
sur france 5 et sur france 3 à amiens
tout alors je suis tous les vendredis
dans l'émission la quotidienne aux côtés
de maya lauqué et thomas hills où je
parle jardin bien évidemment oui puis je
suis également depuis septembre tous les
dimanches après-midi aux côtés de
bernard le coq d'yves lecoq
pardonnez-moi yves lecoq lecoq ont
restauré corps et âme en angle dans le
thème avec yves lecoq dans l'émission
les grands du rire où je parle pendant
37 minutes où j'évoque l'histoire d'un
jardin d'un jardinier ou d'un arbre et
dites moi comment s'est passé l'hiver
les verts a été un hiver normal
les jardiniers ont l'habitude du froid
ils ont l'habitude de la neige
la seule chose qui nous contrarie
beaucoup c'est le temps extrêmement
pluvieux les termes sont humides et
contraignent le travail du jardinier
mais nous avons eu un hiver à peu près
normale et quand je vois aujourd'hui
toute la population qui s'inquiète de
l'épaisseur de la neige est bien là je
me dis que peut-être peut-être que cette
neige aura détruit nous pas mal de
vermine très bien ce qui vous permettra
de continuer votre culture du jardin de
façon bio comme vous faites depuis
toujours sûr on tient compte des
éléments nous sortons nos orangé en mai
nous les rentrons en octobre novembre
nous ne plaisantons pas hors saison nous
récoltons en fonction des du temps on ne
précipite pas la nature on
l'accompagnent on se doit de respecter
la terre respecter l'eau et si ma foi il
ya quelques gelées hâtez-vous tardive et
bien là nous yacco baudot eh bien nous
allons bientôt parler du prochain
printemps en attendant on va
s'interrompre de seconde
enfin quelques minutes pourra recueillir
le témoignage de madame catherine pégard
la présidente
oui je me dois donc de me taire merci
[Musique]
madame la présidente catherine pégard
bonjour merci d'être là pour nous
répondre pour ce vip spécialement
consacré à la cool du mans alors qu'est
ce que ça vous fait d'avoir une nouvelle
habitante au château bah écoutez je
trouve que par-delà l'amusement qu'on
peut avoir en effet aujourd'hui à
accueillir cette poule mais voilà comme
vous voyez être révisée elle entend
compenser la pierre
je pense qu'elle entend qu'on parle
d'elle en effet et bien au delà de cette
anecdote qu'il ya aussi la volonté de
montrer que nous faisons revivre les
jardins de versailles et nous les
faisons revivre évidemment par la
multitude des fleurs qui sont plantés
chaque printemps par les légumes que
l'on est cultivée qui sont maintenant
servi à la table du plaza puisque nous
avons un partenariat avec alain ducasse
qui les cuisines d'accord et puis aussi
le miel du château de versailles dont
nous récoltons un millier de petits pots
un peu quand même
et enfin maintenant cette poule qui je
ne sais pas si elle revient au bercail
parce qu'on est peu informés c'était
justement oui la question allez vous
poser alors est-ce qu'elle existait déjà
c'est pas leur salle marie-antoinette
c'est la foule existe et même bien avant
puisque elle est citée par la fontaine
donc on peut penser que ce louis xiv
déjà la race et s'est taillé la reine a
existé
on peut penser aussi que sous marie
antoinette elle pouvait être ici
puisqu'il y avait beaucoup de races de
poules différentes dans le hameau de la
reine est donc qu'il ya une forte
probabilité qu'elle ne soit pas en
terrain inconnu oui et d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle elle a
l'air déjà s'y habituer à ces rallyes on
peut saluer dans ses gènes lointain elle
retrouve elle retrouve le château de la
serra très bien et alors être qu'elle va
être vus par le public ou alors pour
l'instant elle sera donc dans ce
poulailler qui a été aménagé pour l
extrême et séquelles s'acclimate à ce
lieu est peut-être plus tard on pourra
développer
un petit peu cet élevage et les porter
jusqu'au hameau de la reine puisque
comme vous le savez dans la ferme due à
la maison de la reine va réouvrir et ça
ne se sera sans doute l'un des grands
événements à versailles en 2018 nous
avons restauré la maison ça y est c'est
fait quand pardon le 2 mai dans 2 mai
l'inauguration et ça c'est un scoop je
dirais les travaux seront terminés et
donc on pourra revoir cette maison de la
reine comme on ne l'a jamais vu mecar
meublé comme elle l'était sous napoléon
puisqu'elle a été remodelée par marie
louise qui vouait une grande admiration
à marie antoinette et donc je crois que
pour nos visiteurs qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux à découvrir les triano
faut quand même se souvenir qu'il ya une
trentaine d'années il y avait à peu près
personne qui venait jusqu au trianon 8
sur le château le château du trianon
était loin et aujourd'hui nous
accueillons chaque année un million et
demi de visiteurs rien que dans le
domaine de trianon des couleurs petit
trail c'est une arme de grands
événements comme vous le savez aussi
nous y faisons chaque année une
exposition particulière ni cette année
elle sera consacrée au peintre cocktail
qui a peint les bosquets de versailles
et donc nous verrons à la fois les
peintures de côtes elle est là encore je
peux vous dire qu'on va essayer de
couvrir encore plus largement le spectre
puisque les jardiniers de trianon vont
animer les massifs plantés les massifs
aux couleurs des tableaux au mondial
donc nous allons moi vivre l'ambiance du
18e siècle à trianon où alain temps en
regardant les tableaux et en admirant
les jarres exactement ça va être même
masque aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
quand on prépare une exposition la faire
vivre aussi dans le présent tout notre
objectif aujourd'hui c'est que le passé
éclaire le présent que le présent
s'allumant de se passer
magnifique et qu'on puisse associer
toujours le patrimoine avec la vie
d'aujourd'hui
très bien mais écoutez c'est un beau
programme merci on ne manquera pas de
suivre
merci merci madame abonnés seront oui
merci à bientôt
[Musique]
e
donc l'hiver a été normale comme vous
dites mais les vieux arbres s qui ne
souffrent pas de ce froid tout de même
les armes ne souffre pas parce qu'ils
ont dans le passé connu quantité
d'événements climatiques mais les arbres
aujourd'hui sont en danger parce qu'au
prétexte qu'ils sont souvent creux
dangereux pour être abattus
et justement il ya un projet aujourd'hui
auquel je participe aux côtés de yann
wehrling et lui descend du centre et des
démocrates auprès de valérie pécresse de
travailler sur des textes qui viendrait
à donner à l'arbre remarquable un statut
une protection et j'espère vraiment mais
vraiment du fond du coeur que dans
quelques années les plus vieux ars
d'ile-de-france seront protégés par pas
un texte et qu'ils ne pourront plus être
coupé sauf bien sûr en cas de nécessité
absolue
donc j'aime bien l'idée de nous
intéresser aussi à l'arbre parce que
finalement la remette un peu le grand
oublié de l'autre siècle on parle des
êtres humains forte heureusement on
parle de plus en plus de la condition
animale et c'est heureux monde partent
encore suffisamment des végétaux et des
vieux arbres et j'espère que cette loi
ce texte sur l'arbre remarquable sera
acceptée et permettra aux vieux arbres
comme le disait la fontaine de vivre
encore et milan de plus et donc de
mourir de leur belle mort ben oui je
l'espère vivement d'accord est alors à
versailles le plus vieil arbre quel âge
at il alors nous avons quelques arbres
remarquables le doyen des arbres bien
évidemment c'est un vieux chêne qui
pousse non loin du grand trianon
il ne figure sur aucun plan car le
trouver le maître se mérite un cetain
chaîne ni anonymes anonyme
c'est un chêne et il a germé en 1670
c'est le doyen des arbres de versailles
il existe bien ici même sur les terres
un art qui a connu louis saez le 15 et
louis xiv dans les jardins là l'hiver on
dort tout
quel est le travail du jardinier
actuellement donc là le trait du dernier
consiste à préparer le printemps le
printemps c'est demain oui a fini le
travail car il y aura atrium une
exposition consacrée à côté d'eux le
peintre et nous allons accompagner les
parterres pour que le visiteur découvre
des fleurissements identiques à ceux du
tableau c'est ce que viennent nous dire
madame pégard il ya aussi bien
évidemment les inaugurations la
restauration de la maison de l'arrêt
l'or en mai donc nous devons nous aussi
accompagner ce ce travail au niveau
design tout avait très bien et vous vos
projets personnels alors mais pour le
moment on continue à faire ce que je
fais avec bonheur est en train mais vous
êtes quand vous écrivez des livres mais
je suis en train d'en décrire un bilan
trop tôt pour en parler croteau campagne
a dit d'accord mais simplement ça
concerne les jardins assez bizarre
etonnant non
non mais là je vais parler de jardin en
général oui j'ai quantité de projets de
livres à venir bientôt bon et à marly
qu'est ce qui se passe rien on regarde
le parc on va peut-être devoir couper
beaucoup d'arbres qui sont vieillissants
et dangereux là vous êtes d'accord
oui parce qu'il le il faut de temps en
temps être capable de couper pour
régénérer les uniquement lorsque c'est
nécessaire
très bien mais écoutez alain baraton un
grand merci à vous a très vite alors
pour un nouveau livre avec plaisir vous
nous direz de la roue tourne et à
bientôt j'espère pour les premières
naissances de la poule voilà prévenez
nous dès que le prochain poussins sera
prêt à voir le jour avec joueurs on vous
souhaite beaucoup de bébés merci
beaucoup
à bientôt merci un feu
[Musique]